Bonjour !
Voici la suite de ma vidéo sur les inventions imaginaires,
c'est à dire les inventions qui n'existent pas mais qui pourtant seraient très pratiques au quotidien
Comme par exemple: une vitre électrique anti mec-qui-parle-trop-près-du-visage .
Moi je suis un très très grand fan de Martin Scorsese
Primo la réalisation
Secundo y'a un plan séquence
*bruit de vitre électrique*
Et là tu vois que c'est un truc de malade mon pot...
Wow 'tain mais c'est quoi ça ?
'Faut que tu parles dans le micro !
*bruit de touche*  La réalisation je te disais de Scorses.......
Un accélérateur d'histoires chiantes.
Et donc l'entomologie, c'est la science des insectes!
Et c'est vachement intéressant !
Est-ce que tu as déjà vu les petits poils là sur les papillons ; quand tu les caresse mais que c'est pas ......
*bruit de cassette qu'on rembobine*
C'est comme ça qui je suis devenu bouddhiste.
Ah d'accord
Super histoire c'est cool.
Et tu sais pourquoi je suis devenu bouddhiste ?
Est-ce que tu es déjà allé en Inde mec ?
Les temples ils sont magnifiques ! Ils sont cools...
Une machine pour tenir plus longtemps au lit
Hein. Plus de deux secondes.
Aah vas-y continue
*voix off*  Pensez à un pigeon mort !
Vas-y tu tiens tellement longtemps...
*voix off* Pensez à du vomi dans la rue !
Aah vas-y...
*voix off* Pensez à Alain Juppé !
Ah putain ah  j'suis désolé mais j'ai plus envie là !
Je suis dégoutté ! Ah je suis dégoutté heu.
Un  détecteur de l'origine des mauvaises odeurs
Très pratique pour ces gens qui se lâchent sans pression en public
*bruit d'alarme*
*voix off* l'odeur de proute provient de cette homme !
*raclement de gorge*
*bruit d'alarme*
C'est lui !
*voix off* FAUX
Un anticipateur de postillons
En ce moment, je suis sur une BD super sssouette,  ça s'appelle vaisseau sssuper spacial
Et à un moment, y'a des vaisseaux qui se tirent dessus...
...et ça fait pan pan sslac pan pan tsiouw...
Une montre qui permettrait de disparaître dans les moments gênants
Ça va les mecs; c'est quoi cette musique de merde là ?
Euh c'est notre groupe.
J'suis guitariste.
J'suis chanteur.
*bruit de disparition*
*bruit de ressort*
Un transformateur de films chiants en films cools
Bon ça existe déjà, ça s'appelle la beuh.
Faut pas fumer...
...beaucoup
Dans les moment ou tu sais pas trop quoi répondre à quelqu'un: une télécommande qui permettrait un seconde chance de répartie.
Norman, le YouTubeur, le mec fait plus de vidéos; on est à la retraite monsieur ?
Mais nan je suis pas à la retraite, au contraire, je fais ... 'fin plein de vidéos... 'fin
*bruit de cassette qu'on rembobine*
Moi je suis à la retraite ouais, un peu comme tes ch'veux
*acclamations*
*bruit de corne de supporter*
Bon là j'ai un tête de South Park, parce que j'ai complètement oublié de filmer ce plan avec ma caméra. Ouais j'suis un peu con.
L'invention suivante, ça serai un détecteur d'endroit où ça gratte dans le dos.
*bip bip de la machine*
Alors gratte moi latitude 16 et longitude 25 !
OK
Aah !
Nickel
Une batterie d'I-Phone illimitée
Bon en même temps, ça existe...
... ça s’appelle un fil
Un Wikipédia automatique dans le cerveau.
Tu l'as vu "Le Parrain" ?
*bruit de robot*
Ah oui, tu veux dire ce film réalisé par Francis Ford Coppola ; produit par les studios Paramount, et sorti le 15 Mars 1972 et inspiré du roman éponyme de Mario Puzo ?
Bah ouais c'est ça t'en a pensé quoi ?
Ah.
J'l'ai pas vu !
Mais je l'ai adoré.
Un flouteur de zone que t'as pas envie de regarder
*voix dans la tête de Norman*
Si elle savait que je lui ai flouté le décolleté pour pas être tenté de le regarder. Ha ha je vais passer pour un gentleman
J'ai envie de me faire greffer des yeux bridés !
*voix dans la tête de la fille*
Oh lala si il savait que je l'ai entièrement flouté et que j'entends même pas ce qu'il dit
Ah quel boloss !
Un AdBlock à blagues pas marrantes.
Et tu connais l'histoire de Toto qui rentre dans un bar ?
C'est l'histoire d'un chinois, d'un prêtre et d'un boomerang...
Tire sur mon doigt !
*pet*
Ça c'est pas mal quand même.
Ça serait vraiment pratique pour les mecs pas marrants.
Ouais, donc je disais...
*raclement de gorge*
Donc, ouais je disais...
Ouais nan en fait, c'est pas une bonne idée !
Un détecteur de potentiel de chances avec les meufs.
*voix dans la tête de Norman*
Alors elle 30%; nan
Elle 0% c'est mort elle est avec un mec
Ah, elle 98% OK je me lance
Excuse-moi, je voulais pas te déranger; mais je vois que t'as pris les mêmes chips que moi, c'est marrant
Je me suis dit que, on pourrait aller...heu...
On pourrait aller boire un verre, et parler du fait qu'on aime les mêmes chips et tout enfin...
Bon, je laisse tomber en fait
Et enfin, ce qui serait absolument génial, ce serait un invention qui lorsque vous aimez la vidéo
Mettrait directement un pouce en l'air. Ça, ça ce serait énorme
Ou alors, vous pouvez le faire à l'ancienne
*bruit de clic de souris*
A bientôt
*bruit de disparition*
*générique*